[Music]
Harry Styles is opening up with his new
music and inside the new issue of
Rolling Stone where he gets candid with
Cameron Crowe the interview is the first
time Harry has really addressed his
short-lived relationship with Taylor
Swift quote there's a lot of things that
can be right and it's still wrong
meeting someone new sharing those
experiences it's the best dish to ever
so thank you Perry says he's well aware
that Swift's songs
style
and out of the woods are likely about
him and he's okay with it
quote they're great songs it's the most
amazing unspoken dialogue ever Harry
says his upcoming self-titled album will
feature his own songs about lost loves
apparently his most recent ex is a huge
part of the album remember Harry was
most recently linked with kendall Jenner
so that should be interesting I think
the fun thing about music in general is
that you write oversea write a lot of
stuff from personal experience but it
doesn't necessarily have to be so
literal
[Music]
you